avec nous ce soir José Legault allait
castonguer Christian Dufour bonsoir
bonsoir On va revenir sur le budget deux
éléments baisse d'impôts et est-ce que
la crise du logement a été oubliée oui
ou non mais d'abord revenons sur les
baisses d'impôts je fais entendre un
échange entre Gabriel à dos Dubois et
Monsieur Lebois à la période des
questions aujourd'hui
moi aussi j'ai une suggestion pour son
balado il devrait inviter un travailleur
ordinaire à quelqu'un qui travaille fort
qui fait 30000 par année puis essayer
d'y expliquer Dieu dans les yeux en
restant sérieux pourquoi ce travailleur
là mérite 8 fois moins d'aide 8 fois
moins d'aide que son patron ça ferait
super belle épisode il y a même mieux
ces taxes puis respectent pas la classe
moyenne il pense que la classe moyenne
au Québec a pas besoin d'aide c'est son
problème
voilà monsieur Legault ce matin en point
de presse a rencontré des journalistes
par plaider à dire d'autres actions
avant ce budget
on sait on envoyait des chèques aux gens
aussi bon bref plaidoyer pour dire c'est
pas vrai qu'on oublie les gens les plus
démunis un tour de table là-dessus José
Legault est-ce que les les baisses
d'impôts ont bien passé selon vous
ben c'est sûr que la cacahu a été élue
sur cette base là ça faisait partie
quand même de ces engagements principaux
même dans la partielle de Sainte-Marie
Saint-Jean qui écoutait cette Henri 7
ans je mélange toujours
sur les pancartes électorales de la CAF
qui avait monsieur le groupe c'était
écrit en gros le Best d'impôts là les
grosses grosses lettres donc c'est
légitime politiquement maintenant est-ce
que c'est sage au moment où les besoins
en service public explose partout
la question se pose mais il y a pas de
réponse possible puisque c'est en effet
un engagement électoral voilà avec puis
vous avez animé l'émission à la radio
sur l'objet c'était le gros morceau de
ce budget là attendu c'est le budget le
moins secret qui nous a été donné de
voir on aurait pu tous dire ce qu'il y
avait la dent avant comme dit José
promis attendu livrer voilà
ouais et je pense qu'il y aurait été
plus facile de critiquer le gouvernement
même si on le fait quand même sur ces
baisses d'impôts si on avait dû renier
dans les services ailleurs mais quand on
a des hausse du budget de la santé de
7,7% de l'éducation de 6 % de
l'enseignement supérieur de 5 % de
l'environnement de 14 %, c'est difficile
de dire vous financez pas l'éducation et
la santé vous donner des baisses
d'impôts c'est pas ce qui s'est produit
on pige dans le fond des générations en
fait on réduit les contributions font
des générations qui est un fond qui
faisait débat je rappellerai qu'à la
dernière campagne électorale trois des
quatre parties voulaient piger dans le
fond des générations ou y mettre
carrément fin Québec solidaire le Parti
québécois et la coalition Québec avec
les libéraux puisque c'est leur création
que vous voulez le garder mais on
promettait des baisses d'impôts encore
plus importantes que la CAC on aurait
donc financé d'une manière ou d'une
autre en coupant dans les services donc
les parties de position essaient de
décritiquer la modulation de la baisse
d'impôts on aurait dû le faire autrement
à faire différemment mais la manière
dont le finance
c'est quand même assez difficile à
attaquer ça c'est le génie je pense
laquelle ça vient Québec maintenant bien
sûr qu'un point 7 milliards par année on
peut faire d'autres choses avec ça aussi
mais on aurait dû le dire en campagne
électorale et je vous ai raison c'est
les choix qu'on a fait puis on aura
obtenu au gouvernement fortement
majoritaire et dans toutes les analyses
qu'on pouvait lire économique savante
aujourd'hui Christian beaucoup de gens
néanmoins ont dit pour cette année tout
ça se tient parce que comme dit Alex
c'est le fond des générations de toute
façon d'une part et d'autre part on
réinvesti en santé 7,7 c'est beaucoup
d'augmentation en santé
comment vous vous avez analysé d'abord
les belles impôts et les réactions
qu'elles ont suscitées
je trouve que c'est assez gagnant comme
budget pour le gouvernement si jamais le
temps en fait de procéder des baisses
d'impôts parce que toujours des
objections des craintes un budget ça
révèle la vraie nature le gouvernement
contrairement au discours tout court
donc la CAQ révèle sa vraie nature
rappelons que Francis veille la presse
ce matin en fait nous disait que le
Québec était la troisième juridiction la
plus imposée dans le monde que le fan
official au Québec
pour ça et c'est beaucoup plus important
que dans les autres pays de l'OCDE donc
il y a un vrai enjeu
si on a une vision on dit l'État ne peut
pas toujours devenir plus important on
ne peut pas toujours se retourner vers
l'état pour dire il y a des besoins il y
a de plus en plus de besoins il faut
dépasser donc la carte montre sa vraie
nature là-dessus qui est différente de
celle des parties d'opposition qui est
plus une vision de gauche
social-démocrate
québécoise il y a beaucoup de québé qui
trouve que là on paye beaucoup pour un
état qui nous donne des services qui
sont pas toujours de qualité jusqu'où ça
va s'arrêter donc moi je trouve que
c'est assez gagnant pour la cas comme le
dit Alec en fait en plus les dépenses de
regarde augmente pour la peine le
problème c'est plus dans des dossiers
comme le logement social comme
l'environnement des dossiers en fait
pour lesquels on sent que la cacahuète
enthousiasme si vous permettez
l'expression la casse la mesure le
gourmande sa vraie nature définitive
la semaine passée au même panel lorsque
on était à couper puis monsieur Legault
s'est mis à parler des dépenses de santé
mentale ce que j'ai critiqué d'ailleurs
je trouvais que la journée même c'est
pas le temps de le faire beaucoup de
choses ah ça veut dire que dans le
budget il va avoir plus de dépenses
placera tes mentale c'est pas vrai il y
a pas plus de dépenses pour la santé
mentale pour pour la peine donc si le
moment de vérité c'est ça laquelle le
message je vous prends la balle au bord
Malaisie José oui rapidement sur les
baisses d'impôts quand même je pense que
ce qui soulève des questions au-delà de
la légitimité démocratique du geste
c'est son iniquité vraiment leur face
aux gens qui vont en bénéficier c'est
inéquable d'avoir déjà plus il leur
revenu est élevé plus évidemment ils
vont profiter d'une baisse d'impôts
importantes et ça c'est un petit peu la
même chose c'est le même problème
qu'avec les chèques qui avait été envoyé
directement aux gens il y a plein de
gens qui ont reçu des chèques et qui en
avaient absolument pas besoin on est en
situation d'inflation des crises du
logement etc on n'est pas en situation
normale en ce moment et je pense que ce
qui soulève des questions c'est vraiment
c'est iniquité de la formule parce que
les chiffres que vous voyez là qu'on a
sorti hier c'est ça qui a beaucoup fait
réagir aussi les gens mais il faut qu'on
ça c'est des chiffres absolus c'est un
chiffre absolu mais le point de
pourcentage et le même bien sûr c'est
les deux premiers paliers mais
d'imposition mais forcément quelqu'un
qui gagne plus
logements ils en ont fait
là ça dépend complètement
ces 4500 et 9000 envois d'être construit
donc 9114 mais là on a en ajoute sur
quatre cinq ans 5000 dont 1500 cette
année
madame plante réagit monsieur Lego
répond
je m'attends aussi à ce que la ministre
de l'habitation nous disent qu'elle est
son plan par rapport au logement social
je parle pas de logements abordable et
parce qu'à ce moment-ci comme il y a pas
d'argent neuf on sait toujours pas il y
a plus rien c'est comme si on a enlevait
quand on jette le bébé clou du bain
aucun argent nouveau mais pas d'autres
choses non plus qu'est-ce qu'elles font
les 24000 ménages qu'est-ce qu'ils font
qu'est-ce que le message à ce qui doit
entendre
que il faut travailler ensemble comme je
le disais quand on passe par l'OMH ça
prend quatre ans construire donc quand
même qu'on ajouterait qu'on ajouterait
de l'argent il y avait déjà avant le
budget de l'argent pas dépenser c'est
extrêmement spécial donc il faut trouver
le moyen
d'accélérer la délivrance de permis la
recherche de terrain etc etc
donc quand Christian dit un budget ça ça
révèle beaucoup de choses avec là-dessus
monsieur le goûté là on a financé puis
ils arrivent pas à construire assez vite
alors on va on va réduire le tempo
il y a deux gros problèmes dans ce
budget là c'est l'habitation et la
justice qui sont deux droits
fondamentaux qu'on est en train
d'échapper au Québec les délingeistes
sont longs c'est inabordables les gens
sont plus capables de se payer des
avocats puis d'aller faire reconnaître
leur droit en cours et avoir un toit un
droit universel reconnu et il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui sont plus
capables de se loger ou alors et cela je
mets c'est tellement cher il doit couper
ailleurs il y a de plus en plus de
travailleurs qui ont recours aux banques
alimentaires même s'ils ont deux
salaires parce qu'il paye plus de 50% de
leurs revenus pour se loger toutes les
villes au Québec sont en mode 2 % de
toute inoccupation c'est 0,4 % gramme B
0,8% Gatineau il y a une vraie crise du
logement et là j'ai reçu à Éric Girard
le ministre de la des Finances à
l'entrevue ce midi à mon émission je
l'ai talonné là-dessus parce que j'ai
l'impression que des fois on ne comprend
pas en haut lieu la crise du logement et
il m'a dit un certain point vous savez
c'est complexe il y a pas de solution
simple à des problèmes complexes et
c'est vrai mais le travail du
gouvernement c'est de trouver des
solutions à des problèmes complexes il y
a un certain point il me disait tous les
le groupe de pression évidemment ne sera
pas contents ce n'est pas une question
de groupes de pression il y a des gens
qui ne sont pas capables de se loger
décemment ou alors ils sont obligés de
faire des compromis pour des choses
vitales comme la nourriture on est rendu
un point de rupture les villes ont
raison et je sais que c'est complexe
c'est complexe construit ça coûte cher
la main d'oeuvre et pour rendez-vous etc
mais il faut trouver une manière de
régler ça parce que c'est en train de
devenir un problème immense un grand
jamais l'impression qui en manque un peu
de sensibilité au gouvernement sur cette
un grand chantier José un grand chantier
parce que beaucoup de gens disent ils
sont ne construisent pas assez
d'immeubles à logements il y a des
condos tout ça mais il manque
d'immeubles un logement bref
sensibilité dialecte qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez
je suis d'accord avec tout Québec vient
de vient de dire on a vraiment
l'impression qu'il y a un effet de bulle
en quelque part au gouvernement où on ne
comprend pas la réalité du vrai monde là
je reprends un peu l'expression de
Valérie plante beaucoup de vraiment de
vivre des situations très difficiles en
ce moment et la pénurie de logements
parce que la crise de logement ça c'est
la pénurie de logements abordables
sociales en bon état etc oui c'est
complexe c'est multifactoriels mais moi
je me dis
si Christian Dubé cherche des Top Gun là
pour son agence de santé je pense que ce
gouvernement là a besoin d'être Top Gun
pour s'occuper de la crise du logement
puis pas nécessairement qui viennent du
privé par exemple mais c'est cette
volonté là qu'on ne sent pas et cette
insensibilité à ce que les gens est-ce
que beaucoup de gens vivent les prix des
logements en ce moment à Montréal et en
région mais parce qu'il à Montréal sont
quand dans le l'offre est rarissime et
les conditions qui sont imposées souvent
parce que bon beaucoup de propriétaires
ont gros bout du bâton sont absolument
abusives alors tout ça quand on quand on
parle de Far West là ça veut dire qu'on
a besoin d'un shérif alors il est où le
ou la shérif c'est certainement pas la
ministre de l'habitation en ce moment ça
c'est sûr et certain alors on s'en va on
est déjà dans une crise sociale on va
vivre une fracture sociale bientôt c'est
rien n'est fait de sérieux on veut pas
devenir comme d'autres grandes villes où
il y a des extrêmes là qui se vivent
dans la situation du logement
et le ministre des Finances puis ce
genre était très intéressant et très
révélateur parce qu'avec le confronter
pas mal et on a vu en fait que la vision
du gouvernement était très différente
c'est vrai que la sensibilité est pas
beaucoup là mais je crois pas moi je
suis pas sûr que le gouvernement
reconnaisse que un droit fondamental au
logement on s'entend sur le plan humain
sur le plan social on veut que tout le
monde soit bien logique mais si on parle
les droits fondamentaux je suis pas sûr
que le gouvernement voit ça de la même
façon que la justice
par exemple et c'est clair que quand au
gouvernement la solution c'est pas juste
les logements sociaux c'est pas juste le
gouvernement du Québec il a répété
répété Alex et complexe c'est complexe
donc dans ce sujet-là je le répète le
gouvernement italien j'ai écouté mes
deux mes deux collègues faire leur
plaidoyer très sensibles c'est vrai
qu'un crise du logement mais mais le
gouvernement peut cette vision là je
pense qu'il prend intervenir bah il
rappelle que c'est compliqué mais il se
sent pas à ce point responsable comme
mes deux collègues voudraient que le
cinéma se sente voilà bien résumé
c'est bien résumé je me je me tais on
passe à l'autre sujet parce que c'est
bien résumé
troisième lien rapidement rapidement
on va écouter monsieur Legault ce qu'on
peut écouter monsieur Legault sur le
troisième lien
c'est très court c'est 7 secondes on va
écouter monsieur
quelques semaines l'étude d'achat endage
puis là on pourra répondre à vos
questions avec des données
attendons d'ici quelques semaines on va
pouvoir répondre à vos questions vos
données là c'est l'analyse à la mode
c'est de dire
Christian je vais commencer avec vous ça
se fera pas finalement être un boulet
ils vont s'apercevoir que les les
données d'achat endage ne justifient
peut-être pas autant d'argent on en est
où dans ce dossier là
moi je commence à être heureux parce que
on en parle je pense qu'on en parle plus
beaucoup je pense que ça se fera pas je
suis caricature mais le budget là je le
répète ça dit ce que le gouvernement
veut faire réellement on en dit pas un
mot dans ce budget monsieur Legault est
un peu enlisé dans ce dossier là mais
moi je peux prophète mais j'ai
l'impression que je vais être content
parce qu'on va moins parler
Christian je pense que le troisième lien
il va se faire et que la construction va
commencer le premier avril avec des
poissons dans notre dos alors non ça ne
se fera pas ça ne se fera pas c'est en
train de devenir un poisson d'avril le
troisième bien grosso modo et ce serait
pas une mauvaise chose non plus que ça
ne se fasse pas êtes-vous sûr que ça
je sais pas si sûr que ça mais disons
que l'étude de la santé publique sur la
qualité de l'air dans la base ville est
devenue donner un coup assez solide dans
ce projet-là me souvenez qui a tué le
projet de casino à Montréal c'est avec
le signe du soleil c'était la santé
publique à l'époque là on dit on ne peut
pas avoir un troisième lien qui aboutit
en basse ville pour la qualité de l'air
des résidents ce serait épouvantable
et je pense que ce n'est pas
l'achalandage qui va tuer le troisième
lit c'est son coup parce que dans la
région de Québec on veut un troisième
lien on est des conservateurs fiscaux
avant tout et quand la facture va être
dévoilée je pense que bien même à Québec
déjà qui vont dire on se paye pas ça le
coup par voiture j'ai quand même un lien
et le coup par voiture peut-être on peut
acheter un hélicoptère à un groupe de 10
ok
changer l'heure Christian
du fantôme monsieur poirievre monsieur
Blanchet et Monsieur Trudeau la question
c'était est-ce que il y aura une annonce
jeudi ou vendredi suite à l'entretien
avec le président américain qui débarque
demain soir on écoute
médecin
pour que les entreprises canadiennes
mettent fin au douane sur notre water
pour supporter nos travailleurs dans la
forêt et sécuriser notre frontière on a
en empêchant la migration
illégale au chemin Roxane et ailleurs
mais c'est vraiment juste intro qui est
à la capacité de fermer le chemin Roxane
il devrait le faire c'est lui qui
indique que
c'est le responsabilité de Joe Biden de
protéger nos frontières moi je crois que
c'est le premier ministre du Canada qui
doit protéger le frontière des Canadiens
et comme premier nest je prendrai le
responsabilité pour nos propres filles
frontières et je mettrai fin à
l'immigration
illégale en mars qu'on voit maintenant
il faut être prêt à dire écoutez si vous
n'êtes pas prêt à renégocier l'entendre
sur les diapi sûr le Canada se prévaudra
d'une disposition déjà existante dans
l'entente selon laquelle on peut la
suspendre unilatéralement je veux qu'on
fasse le travail rapidement et ça c'est
pourquoi j'ai dit que le groupement peut
suspendre l'entente et puis on peut
régler ces choses immédiatement
ça fait plusieurs mois qu'on travaille
de proche avec les Américains pour
établir la situation à au chemin Roxane
de regarder l'entendre sur les tiers
bien sûr on va continuer notre travail
puis on va peut-être
mal entendu on va peut-être dit-il avoir
quelque chose annoncé très rapidement il
y aura-t-il quelque chose d'annoncé
est-ce qu'il y aura un déblocage en
dossier là José tour de table
aucune idée mais on l'espère on l'espère
tous là et je pense que politiquement
monsieur Trudeau a besoin d'avoir un
petit quelque chose sur la table un
petit quelque chose à mettre sur la
exactement Alec
vous savez que c'est rencontre là sont
scriptées pas mal d'avance si le premier
ministre du Canada s'étire le coup en se
disant je vais peut-être avoir quelque
chose à annoncé je pense que des bonnes
chances qu'il y a quelque chose annoncé
est-ce que ça veut dire que ça va être
l'annonce globale qui règle tout ça je
suis moins certain mais je pense qu'il
va peut-être y avoir quelque chose comme
un progrès d'annoncé d'ici vendredi soir
je suis pas sûr que Christian va être
totalement donc soulager après l'annonce
de vendredi
parce que ça sera peut-être pas aussi
simple que on ferme puis on a plus
personne qui passe lol avoir le bon côté
évidemment c'est que tout le monde admet
qu'il faut fermer ça c'est un cancer
pour régler ça tout le monde qui est
très destructeur et là-dessus je dois
dire que je suis d'accord avec Paul
lièvre sur le fond je passe souvent
d'accord avec lui quand tu dis que
fondamentalement c'est la responsabilité
du président du Canada je suis d'accord
avec ça c'est un des rôles principaux de
l'état de reste de faire respecter les
frontières c'est un des rôles principaux
de Trudeau je le dis si on peut le faire
par d'autres moyens je m'en fous mais il
faut fermer ça
il nous reste quelques secondes chacun
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas dessiné c'est
pour ça que vous êtes des analyses
politiques c'est une visite quand même
peu importe les résultats on verra mais
ça reste important comme visite José
c'est tout à fait deux jours un premier
ministre un président américain qui
vient au Canada c'est c'est
exceptionnel et je pense qu'avec tout ce
qui se passe sur la terre en ce moment
oui oui je pense qu'il manqueront pas de
sujets de conversation
toutes les petites possibilités de
convaincre le gouvernement américain
qu'on existe et qu'on a besoin d'une
certaine sensibilité sur certains sujets
protectionnisme environnement tout ce
qu'on peut faire pour dire adjo badenois
on est là on le prend c'est important
Christian comme
visiteurs que je surveiller je suis
concret je suis concret pour les
Québécois je pense que c'est ça
merci beaucoup au revoir à demain après
à la prochaine salut